Central Bank digital currencies are
coming and they're going to steal your
money during times of political and
economic uncertainty central banks like
to print more money in order to
stimulate the economy of course it
pushes us deeper into inflation but
anyway we could get to a point where
central banks say in order to stimulate
the economy we're actually going to need
money to change hands and so if Euro
spend at least 50 percent of what you
have in the bank account in the next
three months let's say then that money
is going to expire and yes they can do
this because that money sitting in your
bank account is going to be a central
bank digital currency like I said this
isn't money it's a digital voucher the
central bank and the government can
decide how you spend it and when it
expires and so if your money expires
which it's going to do you're not going
to be able to build long-lasting
generational wealth which means you're
going to be forever a slave to the
nine-to-five system